In comics' Golden Age, Dr. Fate committed
at least two genocides.
In More Fun Comics #61, Dr. Fate is flying
through space when he sees "a strange nebula"
with a flaming globe at its core hanging around
Earth.
Somehow, this breaks Earth's orbit around
the sun, almost freezing the planet before
Dr. Fate destroys the nebula with an "atom
shatterer" he "found on distant Uranus."
But then he finds a whole fleet of nebulae
coming for the earth and traces them to what
he calls "a pirate planet."
So Dr. Fate throws the whole planet into the
sun and kills everybody on it.
You'd think one genocide's already too many,
but Dr. Fate goes for another in More Fun #65.
The fish-men of Nyarl-Amen, who look kind
of like reverse mermaids, rise out of the
sea to conquer the earth.
Fate hunts down their underwater city and
blows it to smithereens.
The narration assures readers that "its fallen
ruins shelter no single thread of life except
a fish or two."